today I'm gonna give me perspective on
10 things you are unlearned in 2019 you
know a lot of you before I get into the
content today ask me about how I create
content is there a content creator that
gives me ideas today I'm gonna introduce
you to my content creator she's amazing
she gives me all this great content come
here let's introduce you to everybody
what is your name my little princess
her name is Senna Rose Bay David and she
gives me all my content you're okay go
go back to what you were doing go baby
anyways okay let's get right into a ten
things too on Lauren in 2019 this is
purely perspective on thinking in a
complete different way number one many
many years you and I have heard that
statement of you are six degrees of
separation you are six degrees away from
the president six degrees away from a
billionaire six degrees away from
Michael Jordan six degrees away from
anybody today it's no longer six degrees
today you're probably two degrees away
from anybody if you go look at your
social media what I would love to see
happen one if somebody was able to put
this technology together
imagine you're eight hundred friends you
have on Facebook Twitter whoever it is
that you follow personally that you know
if there was a way for you to be able to
know who they knew who they had contact
with whose phone number they had who's
you know email address they had you
literally become one or two degrees away
from being connected with the president
connected with anybody it's a complete
different ballgame today than ever
before so don't look at it as a big deal
how do I get in how do I have a meeting
with that CEO how do I have a meeting
with this billionaire how do I have a
meeting with that politician how do I
have this meeting with this influencer
not today it's easier than ever before
you got to unlearn thinking it's a big
deal to get connected with an influencer
number to being a celebrity today it's
no longer what it was in the 80s let me
explain in the 80s there was no YouTube
star in the 80s there was no hey
sensation this person had a beautiful
body poster picture 4.9 million
followers nothing like that existed in
the 80s if you had a nice body you look
good in Miami you look good in LA maybe
you look at a beach in you know you went
to in Italy or you want to Spain and
they knew
how pretty you were but they only knew
you in that city they only knew you in
that town today the world knows who you
are so the value of being a celebrity is
not what it used to be in the 80s
meaning if somebody like you meet
somebody there's a big difference
between a celebrity versus being an
influencer an influencer positive
influences somebody is positively
impacting people's lives if you are
going to make a decision to be anything
a lot of people say oh I'm an influencer
I'm an influencer I'm an influencer
there are many ways to be influencers
there could be negative influence it
could be you know influence just because
your body your body's not gonna really
do anything to me it's just wow she's
gorgeous wow he's got nice abs but to be
an influencer where you are positively
impact in the world through whatever
methods you have to do that's a complete
different story so nowadays the value of
celebrity now we're used to be in the
80s if you're a positively impact in the
world and you're an influencer that's a
completed fun place to be my challenge
to you is to start thinking about
celebrity this way I want to be an
influencer not as much as being a
celebrity for the right reasons number
three meaning of money if there's
anything you can learn about money is
how money works and your relationship
with money money is very interesting
think about it this way
money is the person you know in your
life where if you allow them to allow
them to they will use you you ever met
anybody that if you allow them to
they'll use you they'll abuse you
they'll bully or you ever have somebody
like that in your life that's money but
that same person if you lead them they
realize you can be pushed around that's
money if money realizes you're putting
money to work not the other way around
money says so you know what I found a
leader I'll follow this person because
money loves to be led money loves to be
put to work but most people don't know
how to put money to work if you don't
put money to work money goes out there
and does other things and works for
somebody else so your relationship one
is money's got to change start thinking
it as a tool start thinking about in a
complete different way if you've never
watched your video 20 rules of money
Mario let's put a thumbnail up here
click over here to go watch a video 20
rolls of money and then after that go
watch the next video call how to double
your money it'll give you completed from
perspective out how money works going
into 2019 the next thing to unlearn
enos political beliefs let me explain to
what I mean by this listen don't if
there's anything you can pick up in 2019
that can help you out as a following
don't let any of the media outlets
emotionally confuse you and make you
change your mind let me explain to you
imagine I got two people here okay
they're both trying to sell their ideas
on to you one of them gets up based on a
ton of research done by Pew Research
that's not Republican that's not
Democrat this is not Fox News research
that's Republican this is not CNN MSNBC
research that's Democrat I'm talking
somebody that is you know not
necessarily leaning on one side
politically this person gets up and
makes her case to you and they say
here's what's going on right now here's
what's happened with the economy this is
what's taking place in this area here's
why this has taken place this is what
the percentage is for instance hey you
know people going back to prison I'm
making an argument to telling you
recidivism rates right after one year of
a person being out of prison 56 percent
end up back in prison okay so I went
into prison I get out 56 percent of
inmates that got into prison and left go
back in a year later 67 percent is three
years later 76 percent is five years
later that stats right and I give you a
story
another person gets up and it's purely
emotion but they're unfair but they have
no idea what they're doing they don't
really care about people they don't
really care about this but there is zero
fact they're only talking emotion don't
fall for it I want both I want to hear
emotion cool that makes sense I'm really
felt the pain but I also want logic give
me some data give me some numbers so if
you're Republican and you only watch fox
news you're blinded if you're a Democrat
and you only watch CNN you're blinded
you need both I want both I want to
watch and read all of it I've read
Republican books I read Democratic books
don't get too blind in this area in 2019
because there's gonna be a lot of games
in 2019 and 2020 when it comes down to
politics don't be naive by the way image
someone that's watching this right now
saying I'm not gonna be naive
yet you still only listen to the stuff
that you like to hear that you agree
with you're still not making your
argument stronger you got to be able to
listen to everything kind of get an idea
but if you got into blind spots they're
number five meaning of friendship what
is the meaning of friendship look you
party with your friends I had one of our
guys the other day who's one of our top
earners in the company Ricky angular
said just because I partied with you for
three four five years doesn't make you
my best friend it just means we party
together or not at that time I enjoyed
it he says I have made a decision to
grow my life in a whole different place
and I'm realizing those people aren't
friends there were people I partied with
there's a big difference between people
I partied with and people that I'm
friends with and I think a lot of times
people emotionally say well you know I
just Larry and John you know we stir
party together man I feel like we have
very deep roots
no no that's partying that doesn't mean
someone's gonna defend you and back you
up to help you go to a next level when
it becomes friends how many times you
see these posts on Instagram where
somebody says you know Oh bro you know I
got a job congratulations I got my
college degree congratulations I'm
starting my business all my gosh you
know go two separate direction you seen
those memes you know it lets you say
there's some truth to that you realize
who your friends are so in 2019 really
eliminate some of those people that you
thought we're friends that you party
with get rid of them and replace them
with some people that actually can go
deeper root it with values principles
things that can help you become a better
human being
redefine the meaning of friendship to
you number six family support I can't
tell you how many times people tell me
things like Patti you know what do I do
my mom and dad don't support me you know
they don't support me for what I'm doing
my mom didn't support me to become an
entrepreneur I'll get messages after
messages after mess on Instagram they
don't support me they don't support me
here's one thing you got to realize most
parents are not going to support your
dreams just realize that they're not
your job is to make them know if it's
real or not and by the way if your
dreams are 100 percent important to you
and they become a reality guess what
your parents say wow he was serious when
I first told my dad I'm gonna get into
the financial industry let me take my
dad told me here's what my dad told me
my dad said how are you gonna go be a
financial adviser a mortgage
stanley dean witter when you have
$49,000 a death how are you gonna do it
and guess what I sat down I said maybe
this guy makes sense and I almost quit
the financial industry first time here
at me speak year and a half I was
speaking in front of 500 people at an
event and he says you were on stage I
said yes he says you're 22 years old why
are they listening to you speak and so
I'm starting to make a name for myself
in the world of business and then he
became a believer not the other way
around don't try to win your family
support and said my parents don't
support me that's why I didn't make it
Helene I know many people that didn't
have family support they made it then
their family said we respect you because
even though we didn't support you you
still went through with your dreams
number 7 social media pros and cons you
got to understand both aspects of it
there's a lot of people that only sell
pros there's a lot of people that only
sell cons you need to know both if you
know one thing about me is I like
perspective I want to see both sides and
I give you both sides on social media
let's start off with cons getting hacked
accounts are getting hacked lately
hardcore we got hacked
Mauri what was it four weeks ago five
weeks ago we got hacked let me tell you
what happened you will get emails that
look like this Maury why don't we put up
an image of what the email looks like
the email comes out and it has the
Instagram email everything looks real
and it says click here you have a post
that is unapproved your accounts about
to be deleted because of a something you
broke or something you did wrong etc etc
and they're not approving it right so
all of a sudden what they'll do is
you'll have that email you'll click on
it and you'll log on the moment you log
on
that wasn't an email from Instagram or
Facebook or Twitter or YouTube they go
into your account then they go
immediately change your account password
after they go on your account and change
the account password you don't have
access to your account from there they
automatically go in and do whatever they
want to do this guy got on our value
team an Instagram account he got on he
changed it he changed a handle he
changed everything we lost control for
six hours and it finally I ended up
sending him a message and I told him I
said look you know I I can actually put
you exactly what I wrote in Mari why
don't we put an image of what we told
this person in a response and I put this
respond back then a guy came back he
felt bad he said he gave me the password
him
vitamin activated again we got control
to account but many times this doesn't
happen and by the way Instagram doesn't
have a help account you Facebook to us
and Twitter does in YouTube doesn't many
of these accounts don't so and they may
take a month to get back to you because
you're not that big of a priority if
you're not high-profile so what does it
mean be very careful when you're getting
these emails don't fall for them next
per minute whatever you post on social
media is permanent pictures doing any of
that stuff you may be in your 20s or
teenage you're thinking it's not a big
deal 20 years later it's gonna come back
and catch it catch up to your bullying
there's bullying going on on social
media all the time
I share bullying with you because you
got to share bullying with your kids
Center that doesn't write it over there
you want to go right on the paper
go over there uncle Mario will give you
a paper to write on bolian when it comes
down to social media you got to talk to
your kids about bullying happening all
the time I get these messages parents
always contacting me saying what do I
handle about this what I handle about
that is past week when we were in Palm
Springs with 141 of our execs I talked
to them about how I speak to my kids
about sex how I speak to my kids about
secrets
like I'm not a fan of people saying do
you want to keep a secret
I tell my kids there's only two people
you keep secrets with that's your
parents okay you don't keep secrets with
strangers these are things that you have
to be teaching your kids I think a lot
of times parents are so busy that
they're worried about having the sex
conversation the bullying conversation
the sexting conversation and then and
then all of a sudden it's too late get
out that conversation be prepared for
cameras always on location tracking the
other day we went and ate at Fleming's
Mari had location-tracking
on his what was the snapchat account or
whatever it was one of those accounts
and then all of a sudden boom guy runs
in we have a private room he jumps and
can I shine your shoes can I do this can
I do that and everybody started kind of
panicking a little because the guy was
breathing very hard and he had stuff in
his hand but then we started talking to
me was a stable guy but this has
happened many times I've gone to movies
and my tracker was on with a guy that
took a snapshot of me people showed up
so you just have to know you gotta have
your tracking off you gotta have your
notification off if you don't have your
notification off you will have no life
all of these things will be updating
like your Instagram messages off
snapchat messages off you have so many
things that will haunt you
if you keep your notifications on
opposition I'll tell you what about
opposition when it comes down to social
media there are a lot of people that
don't like people to disagree with them
okay
when I started creating content you know
all of a sudden we started getting one
negative comment to negative common
nowadays we get a hundreds of negative
comments that people post here are some
of them that I have up here you can read
them we get a lot of them some of them
are funny some of them are harsh some of
them are direct so I'm hurt but
regardless if you are planning on
creating content you have to know that
people will oppose you if you can't
handle that you just need to make that
decision whether you want to do it or
not now here's pros connection speeds
cost-effective marketing grant
grandparents are staying in contact with
grandkids because they can do FaceTime
and see the kids your one video away
from being an online celebrity education
accessible to making money today the
youngest youtuber is a 7 year old kid
who made 22 million dollars in 2018 he
is the youngest youtuber highest paid
youtuber 7 years old made 22 million
dollars last year think about this he's
a toy review YouTube channel so there's
so many pros and cons with social media
your understanding about social media
has to change both pros both cons if all
you think about is pros you got to get
the perspective around the concept all
you think about is cons you got to think
about the perspective on the pros number
9 resume 2019 you know how resume has
always been what here's my job here's
where I work here's my degree here's
this here's that let me tell you what
impresses me I'm sitting there hiring
different CFOs and six CFOs are sitting
there giving me their pitch the guy at
the end says the following to me he says
by the way I watched some of your videos
I just want you to know just last week I
ran the mile in 5 minutes and 42 seconds
I see you did what he said I ran a mile
last weekend 5 minutes and 42 seconds
and I'm 46 years old I said you got to
be kidding me no I made a note of it
that stuck with me when I stepped away
why I thought about his health condition
stamina energy to be able to last long
what does this mean to you if I am
applying anywhere today and I'm posting
my resume I'm gonna tell you what I'm
posting here's what I'm putting my
resume if I've traveled the world I'm
letting you know I've travelled the
world because I've seen culture
and I'm gonna explain to you that I know
how to deal with different cultures if I
have contacts to write contacts I'm
gonna put the five contacts that I have
in high places
direct contact cellphone that I have a
relationship with it influence if I have
a certain influence where my following
I'm gonna put on my resume 62,000 people
follow me on Instagram you know ninety
three thousand people follow me on
Facebook I have seventeen thousand
followers on Twitter and their main
niche is to follow in five words I'm
gonna put the books I've read here's a
top five books I've read in business I'm
gonna write it these are the top ten
books I've read I'm gonna sit and say
this guy's read these books yes Wow I
asked you about the book you know about
the book I'm impressed
more than your degree I'm impressed the
books you've read your credit score I've
got a 793 credit score hey I have a 793
credit score credibility discipline your
health I ran a marathon three weeks ago
really which one boston marathon 26.2
miles you ran it yes I did an Ironman
you know I wonder CrossFit whatever
whatever for the state of Texas I'm
impressed
those things today matter on your resume
maybe not twenty years ago today they do
I learn how you view resumes number nine
being a millionaire it's no longer a big
deal that's the easiest time to be a
millionaire
however as easy as it is to be a
millionaire this is also time where more
criticism is given to millionaires so
you have to close your ears to the
criticism of being a millionaire feeling
bad about being a millionaire and you
have to realize it's so easy to go be a
millionaire today truly this the easiest
time to be a millionaire in the world
ever go make your Millions
last but not least meaning of love one
time a good friend of mine were in
Cinque Terre Italy and we have a long
drive from Tuscany I rented a 17 bedroom
mansion in Tuscany all the way up on top
of the mountains and beautiful place
incredible time pool in the backyard
hired chefs all these things and one
that we decided to go to Cinque Terre
it's a beautiful place you've seen on on
postcards before all these houses that
are different color orange yellow pink
and we ended up eating go but they under
drive there we were having a
conversation about that we ran out of
gas on the way up come was pretty bad I
mean I I went into the gas station half
a mile the cars running out I guess it
was a downhill we just passed a red
light and pulled into a gas
we got some guests or else would be in a
bad situation there because there was no
gas stations all on top of the mountain
and we're driving we started talking
about the meaning of love I said tell me
what love means to you and he says love
to me is a feeling an emotion I said I
said to me love means verb love is a
action love is shown he says I don't
know if I agree with you I said that's
totally fine we can have different
meanings of love but if you love
somebody you got to show it to them how
do you show it to them whatever way it
is that you show it to them show is
action show is a behavior so why are we
talking about love right now a lot of
people say they love you but they don't
show you the action you got to kind of
realize who loves you and who doesn't
love you all these people that say they
love you such an easy word to use let me
tell you many many men have used the
word love 10 seconds before they got it
on with somebody okay and it's a magical
word just tell me you love me the guys
like ting ting ting ting ting all the
blood is rush rush to the middle part of
their body and it's I love you baby okay
and they have and it says well I don't
know if I love you like that love is
action love is a lot of work love is a
lot of effort that you got to put into
it yes baby yes or no what do you think
you just want to be in a video so I love
this baby so you know what happens if I
love you what do I do if I love you can
I show you some love yeah I love you I
give you a kiss yes what do I do to love
you I support you I protect you
I tell you're amazing yes I take your
places with me we spend quality time
together we play we wrestle we go
shopping together we go eating together
we spend time together we laugh together
we cry together yes yes or no you know
what all that stuff is what is all that
stuff all that stuff is love baby
so in 2019 redefine the meaning of love
okay really start looking at who truly
loves you if love is truly a verb who is
truly loving on you and love is truly a
verb who are you showing love to
yourself and if you're not make an
effort and if others are not have that
conversation with them and if they still
don't do it then identify who is the
person that you want to get tighter and
identifying that community of love and
who is just an acquaintance you got to
get very clear about your relationships
in 2019
very very clear again let's go back and
debrief what we talked about sixty
degrees of separation today's to being a
celebrity is no longer that tough it's
the ideas about being a positive
influence or the meaning of money
watched a video 20 rules of money
political beliefs emotional versus logic
meaning of friendship family doesn't
necessarily have to support everything
you do social media pros and cons resume
in 2019 being a millionaire meaning of
love I want to hear what else you want
to unlearn in 2019 7 year tweet at
Patrick made David there handles right
in and if you have not yet subscribed to
value Taemin click on the subscribe
button right down here take care
everybody bye-bye